the countess is a burst caster whose
greatest strengths are misdirection and
unpredictability utilizing her abilities
counties can quickly single out and
assassinate a key target and vanish into
the darkness focus on buying cards that
increase your physical damage and mana
dark tide will send out a rolling cloud
that deals damage to all enemies in the
area of effect this is your main source
of damage and it's great for poking
enemies and pushing lanes blade siphon
will cause countess to quickly spin her
blades around her dealing damage it also
comes with a passive component that will
regen a percent of her max health every
time she kills an enemy unit this effect
is amplified when slaying an enemy hero
shadow slip will allow you to teleport
to a target enemy slowing me it will
also leave behind an after image of the
countess if you reactivate the ability
you will return to that image this tool
will allow you to quickly get in and out
of fights and finally your ultimate is
feast the countess will leak to a target
enemy briefly stunning them and dealing
a massive burst of damage when playing
countess look for opportunities to
assassinate key targets once your team
engages the enemy you shadow slip to
leap to enemy damage dealers and quickly
burst them down beast will deal a
massive burst of damage but can also be
used to interrupt enemy abilities